we've done dota we've done csgo but now
it's time to count down the top 10 best
caster calls in League of Legends
history let's kick off the list in style
with the nail-biting near finish of
fnatic vs. oMG at Worlds 2014 from
Rivington casting every second as the
Nexus drew closer and closer to
destruction two Jack and Jill Miller
losing their minds at the exact moment
of fanatics heartbreaks this casting
moment has it all go go he's gonna make
it in that gaze there here comes cyanide
as well on the end they're focused on
the even from the very beginning faker
was insane kicking off his career with
this sixth solo kill on ambition the
move was so quick and brutal in fact it
took a second for it to register with
Doha and Montecristo leading to this now
famous reaction just executes so
efficient that mid lane I think there
was actually probably a problem I was a
fan I have never seen an efficient die
like that anyway there's no pause I mean
you know a play is good if the casters
suggest there might be something wrong
with the opponent's computer sometimes
good casting isn't just about hype
especially when the play is to put it
mildly noobish want proof check out our
pick for number 8 where Samsung neglects
their vision control basics and are
rightfully massacred by najin all
perfectly underscored by Monte Cristo's
laughter
Oh double Cooper dude they call all Todd
the cuvette ending this what it's da
hell oh that was one of the saddest
things though he hasn't played for them
since early 2011
Kobe sometimes shows he still a CLG
loyalist at heart
just listen to his pride in our pick for
number 7 as CLG swept their most bitter
of rivals out of the 2015 na LCS summer
finals to win their first title it just
goes to show sometimes a little faith
goes a long way double is gonna clean
one up 40 seconds on the clock boys and
the faithful shall be rewarded
off meta picks can sometimes send
casters into an absolute tizzy as is the
case for number 6 on this list in fact
kick is his choice of oh dear against
gambit gaming in the 2015 new LCS spring
quarter finals had quick shot over the
moon and he channeled that excitement
into this simple the unforgettable call
Phoenix stands and of course fair stands
and he's already slapped first base slap
do it do it it's going it's going
boys
the board
IV Rosa would style even though D man no
longer caste League of Legends his
legacy lives on in his iconic
catchphrase but perhaps the most famous
occurrence is expec AIDS backdoor which
comes in at number 5 you can see there's
given that case definitely uphold the
Nexus he's trying to do it but meanwhile
agree the fight starts going to
difference of interface we take the
necessary
who doesn't love a sick penta pastry
time definitely does just check him out
in our pick for number four losing his
[ __ ] as deaf cleans house for completely
ridiculous team fight Penta jet finally
makes me think Kofi getting tanked up as
what cleanup actually dies is born goods
back inna makers not here in depth now
feel the way but Cara does so much work
in the fact one but it might not be
enough it port need somebody kill to it
but EQ and senses out and gets the guilt
that's to kill death goes back in
flashes aggressive pong needs ticked
hideaway
yes what the hell gets a trivial kill
gets a quarter gets a pentakill
what on earth is going on demon and Joel
Miller were at the top of their game and
the end of their vocal reserves in our
pick for number three
CLG use amazing comeback against Moscow
five at Dreamhack summer 2012
even with his voice and tatters you can
hear demons passion as he and Joe Miller
close the book on one of lol's greatest
games and that kick comes out three for
price hike sees how the target fighting
wiki picking up another kill I cut off
the lead this is a no yeah put in front
of me diamond bro trying to get away
from this one yellow beets just a jump
on his face any minute now
there we go the shutdown comes in the
ACE comes up and see OT this is insane
60 seconds porn time CLG gonna push this
one through in fact they don't even care
that nosing in before I do okay in them
the nexus story has already gone down
the second nexus story is come down and
CLG pull off the biggies comeback that
we've ever seen in league of legends at
this level absolutely insane more from
Kobe's faith and CLG comes in and number
two experiences euphoria as he watched
CLG pull off one of the most exciting
upsets in league
history by taking down orangey at the
2016 midseason Invitational next history
will fall another will fall 42 minutes
sure some people might have doubted
clg's ability to beat the strong LPL
roster but never Kobe
[Applause]
holy crap taking the top spot on the
list is Monte and doe is iconic call of
the most famous play of all no Baker may
be in trouble your death Bart tries to
clean it up for you oh look at the
cleanse look at the boobs
thank you well I want that faker without
you I'd lay the qss I can't put a virus
though you actually want to the Katy
bullets bass not much more to say about
this legendary bit of casting other than
dole was right you do have to look at
the cleanse and look at the moves to
understand just what makes paper paper
that thing's faker does wins it possible
fight and that's it our picks for the
top 10 caster calls in League of Legends
history but wait you didn't think we'd
leave you without a little Korean caster
madness did you enjoy our honorable
mention and we'll see you next time okay